let's bring in Mike Florio Pro Football
Talk Pro Football Talk comm Mike joins
me here on the show Mike just your
reaction to the store in the Detroit
news about Matt Patricia I mean it is
amazing Chris in this day and age that
it was kept quiet for so long somebody
referred to it as a skeleton in the
closet this is a scale and that was out
of the closet this is an indictment this
is a public event it's a public record
it's a it's a big deal guilt or
innocence set aside when a grand jury
convenes and decides that there is
enough evidence to conclude that there's
probable cause to believe that the crime
was committed and an indictment comes
and the case is set on a course toward
trial that is a big deal the trial
didn't happen there was no opportunity
for the allegations to be proven or
disproven but the indictment makes it a
big deal that causes it to take on a
higher level of significance and I think
you know you're talking about the lion's
not knowing about this I think there's
just a certain assumption that when a
guy has a public life as a football
coach and he's rising in the ranks and
his name is coming up repeatedly for
head coaching jobs if there was anything
like that out there it would have come
out at some point and you know if you're
gonna dot every I and cross every T you
are gonna find this out but I can
understand why a team like lions would
just assume that if this guy had been
indicted at some point during his adult
life we would know about it by now and
we just simply didn't okay so how big a
problem is this from a Patricia well you
know from a legal standpoint I doubt
that there's any statute of limitations
it hasn't run yet either criminal or
civil so if the alleged victim at this
point has a change of heart I don't
think that's an issue but it's a PR
problem for the Lions for Patricia and
possibly for the league office and we've
seen how the league reacted to the Ray
Rice fiasco from a few years ago we've
seen how the league has handled various
allegations against players it's much
more a PR function than it is at least
in my opinion an effort to get to the
truth and mete out justice the Ezekiel
Elliott was a prime case of PR trumping
the idea of whether or not a guy
actually did what he's accused of doing
because as EQ Elliott never got a fair
chance to defend himself in that setting
so if PR takes over and this does on
fold in a certain way for the Lions you
know if the alleged victim decides to go
on 60 minutes or or ESPN or somewhere
else and sit down and tell her story and
if she tells her story in a convincing
way regardless of whether or not it's
actually true that could be the kind of
thing that creates a snowball effect for
the lion so I think I understand why
they came out with their statements last
night if I was advising Matt Patricia
I'd say you have to give a stirring
passionate convincing shout from the
rooftops defense of yourself today
because that's what people who are
falsely accused do and then we just hope
we can move forward and this dies down
but that that's that's where PR I think
takes a front seat and the legal system
takes a backseat because at this point
it's not about the legal system it's
about the court of public opinion a case
that was never tried in a court of law
potentially is going to be tried in the
court of public opinion and the lions
and Patricia I think at this point among
other things have to hope that the
alleged victim doesn't decide to engage
in that trial in the court of public
opinion the Lions probably should have
done or should have uncovered this know
during their research on Patricia but
does a guy like Patricia going for a job
like this does he have a responsibility
to bring this up to get in front of it
or or no well I I don't think that
there's a responsibility on him to wear
on his sleeve things that would be
readily available if if a basic criminal
background check was done on the guy and
there are certain limitations on what
you should and shouldn't ask and I
remember when I was practicing law there
was kind of a line there between asking
someone about convictions and asking
someone about arrests because a lot of
people get arrested and a lot of those
people never get charged never get
convicted never are found responsible
this is the gray area in between where
you do have a grand jury that has
determined that an indictment was
required and I'm in the process of
getting my hands on that the guidelines
that the NFL gives to the teams about
the things that can and can't be asked
during an interview of a head coach and
I think too this isn't like an
entry-level sales job somewhere I have a
feeling that that as a practical matter
what gets asked of these guys is more
perfunctory and more so
well than what it would be in another
setting because I mean the Lions were
determined to hire Matt Patricia from
the moment Bob Quinn became the GM two
years ago
and Bob Quinn has worked with him Bob
Quinn knows and Bob Quinn isn't in a
position where he's going to do the same
kind of extensive background check that
he would for somebody he doesn't know
and and maybe that's the lesson for
these teams going forward you need to
engage the procedures that are out there
it doesn't take much time it's worth the
extra little bit of elbow grease just to
avoid the embarrassment because in a
minimum even if they had known about it
and they would have hired him anyway
they're in a position where they can
control the narrative Chris and they can
get it out there on their terms instead
of being caught flat-footed like they
were last night when the Detroit News
puts its story out Martha Ford is the
owner of the Detroit Lions she's been a
strong advocate for domestic violence
victims in the past you think that plays
a factor in all this as we move forward
well I think it potentially does but it
all depends upon how big of a reaction
there is I I think this is the point now
where we just sit back and we wait and
we see what kind of a groundswell there
is or there isn't directed at the Lions
directed at the league how what kind of
public pressure is going to be placed on
the Lions or the league to do something
about this and we've seen that in
different situations there is an intense
amount of public pressure that comes to
bear how big of a story is it going to
be are they going to cover it on the
national network news shows or is it
going to be something that's confined to
the sports media I mean these are all
these are all factors that I think for
the lines and the team and then the
league rather they just sit back and
wait and see how it unfolds and how big
of a story it becomes and then I think
you have to react to it
if it does end up becoming a bigger
story and if it becomes if it becomes
too big and there are too many people
who are saying this isn't acceptable
that's when the league office has to
decide whether or not to make a
difficult phone call to the league and
say you guys need to do something about
this but that that's all to be
determined that's just one possible way
this could shake out but if I'm the
Lions right now Chris I mean I've got my
my list of all possible outcomes in
worst case scenario is you know there's
an overwhelming outcry and we're in a
position where we may have to do
something we don't want to do always
great to talk to you Mike I appreciate
the insight all right Chris take care
pal that's Mike
Florio pro football talk pro football
talk calm joining me here on the Dan
Patrick show for more Dan Patrick show
to the audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]